il y a eu la pandémie bien sûr qui a eu
la reprise économique l'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine maintenant est-ce que les
chaînes d'approvisionnement mondial vont
finalement se remettre à fonctionner
normalement avec nous pour en parler
Martin Humblot le président directeur
général de l'Administration portuaire de
Montréal le port de Montréal bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez dit aujourd'hui dans
un discours que vous avez présenté
devant les gens d'affaires au
centre-ville de Montréal que les ports
en général étaient devenus des sites de
stockage plutôt que des zones de transit
expliquez-nous qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
et qu'est-ce qui se passe présentement
on a vécu littéralement quatre crises
différentes au cours des trois dernières
années la demande de l'offre des
congestions et vous avez fait référence
au conflit craignez et la dernière crise
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé dans
le passé ça fait en sorte que le
stockage est plein partout les entrepôts
sont plein partout et ça a refoulé
jusqu'au port et donc les conteneurs ne
pouvaient pas quitter le port et aller
dans les entreprises donc momentanément
pour quelques mois on grandes angles de
stockage alors que on doit assurer la
fluidité ça doit sortir rapidement là ça
va beaucoup mieux depuis le mois de
septembre mais c'est une situation qui
nous a préoccupé pourquoi ça va mieux la
consommation reprise et on n'a pas
nécessairement l'entièreté des réponses
et la raison pour laquelle je disais ce
midi on doit travailler sur un nouveau
modèle d'affaires parce que si la
situation revient l'an prochain et on
n'a pas changé un peu le modèle
d'affaires on va revivre cette situation
là ça veut dire quoi changer le modèle
d'affaires l'une des choses que l'on
pense c'est d'avoir de grands centres de
transbordement et de stockage qui sont
partagés plutôt que d'avoir du stockage
morcelé un peu partout c'est de
rassembler ses capacités là et de les
centraliser à des endroits qui sont
névralgiques moins cher moins de
transport moins de GS il y a des parts
qui fonctionnent comme ça qui
fonctionnent vraiment bien donc quelque
part sur la réussite si on avait cette
zone tampon on pense que ça aiderait
beaucoup à chaque logistique et ça veut
dire quoi partager des sites partager
avec qui réfléchissez à un gros entrepôt
Amazon pour ne mais plutôt d'être
appropriété d'une seule entreprise c'est
un consortium et qui loue les espaces et
donc les entreprises du Québec les PME
du Centre du Québec ou du Nord peuvent
utiliser les espaces comme zone tampon
pour leur propre conteneurs avant que ce
soit cheminé chez eux donc ça permet de
fluidifier la chaîne de justice et là
vous êtes là vous me dites que ça va
mieux là mais on pourrait avoir besoin
de cela dans le futur moi je pense que
c'est incontournable on a fait également
référence au fait que nous on va
accroître notre capacité d'environ 60%
dans les prochaines années on va
construire on va construire la
contrecoeur un nouveau terminal hyper
moderne tant mieux ça va être en place
en 20 26 c'est nécessaire mais
insuffisant ça prend aussi dans les
régions limitrophes c'est centre de
transbordement et de stockage parce
qu'on va vouloir sortir de Contrecoeur
et dans des endroits névralgiques pour
aller sur les autoroutes et beaucoup sur
le ferroviaire et ça prend des ondes
tampons et les centres de distribution
vont servir à d'où vient cette
augmentation pourquoi cette cette hausse
importante dont vous parlez vous parlez
de l'augmentation 60% même qui sera pas
encore suffisante c'est à dire que le
port à 60% on va on va être correct pour
un très très un bon bouton comme on dit
mais il faut éviter les périodes de
pointe donc même quand contrecarpe est
en service on va vouloir sortir les
commodités assez rapidement contrecar ça
a été développé parce que Montréal
grandissait mais aujourd'hui il y a une
autre perspective derrière ça à cause
des crises logistiques on a besoin de se
terminal là encore davantage mais on est
aussi besoin d'infrastructure
accessoires au simple terminal ce sont
des retombées économiques qui se chiffre
en milliard ça ressemble à quoi vous
savez tout le monde parle de la
production puis la consommation ultime
le transport là c'est le lien entre la
production et la consommation quand nous
on va mal dans le transport au milieu
c'est l'ensemble de la chaîne économique
qui paye pour on a entendu madame d'Agen
de la SAQ quand une répercussions
économiques sur le transport c'est
l'ensemble de la chaîne qui qui prend un
coup et l'année passée les coûts de
transport ont augmenté de façon très
importante et ça a même contribué à
l'inflation à laquelle vous avez
référence d'entrée de jeu dans votre
émission est-ce que tu mens pour réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
cela dit on devrait diminuer le
transport moins important moins exporté
moins échangés je dis ça parce qu'on est
dans un monde très mondialisé depuis
longtemps mais qui où le protectionnisme
c'est quand même beaucoup invité au
cours des dernières années vous avez
raison on n'est pas du tout à Montréal
dans la croissance absolue on veut
soutenir l'économie du Québec nous on
est là comme service public pour
accompagner cela dit le transport ça
peut se décarboner de différentes façons
il y a des solutions aujourd'hui au port
de Montréal on a un des rares parts à
avoir des solutions électriques pour les
navires qui sont acquis deuxièmement
l'ensemble de notre écosystème est en
train de s'éctrifier et troisièmement je
suis persuadé qu'on va être capable
bientôt d'avoir des liquides verts qui
vont permettre de décarboner les navires
ils vont être véritablement des vecteurs
de la transition énergétique est-ce que
vous avez baissé ou pas de Montréal vous
vous émissions de gaz à effet de serre
absolument on les baisse constamment et
on est à la porte d'être carbone neutre
bientôt on a une situation favorable
évidemment avec notre électricité mais
on émet très très peu de GS dans nos
propres opérations les faut s'occuper du
camionnage il faut s'occuper des navires
et là faut s'occuper du tunnel Louis de
La Fontaine au cours des prochaines
années où il y aura des travaux majeurs
ce qui va ralentir le transport le
camionnage notamment est-ce que ça peut
vous affecter
évidemment nous il y a environ le 2 %
des camions qui passent de 2% des
transports qui passent par le tunnel qui
viennent au port c'est pas beaucoup mais
c'est quand même significatif pour la
chaîne logistique donc on travaille sur
une multitude de solutions pour
minimiser les impacts et des solutions
des fois ces technologiques des fois
c'est le logistique ou des fois c'est
comportementales des choses assez
simples que nous on a déployé qui sont
en place c'est un portail qui permet
d'évaluer le temps d'attente avant de se
présenter au port un camion qui attend
on part c'est mauvais deuxièmement quand
on sort du port on va aussi informer les
camionnettes pour à peu près 50% de nos
volumes c'est le camion 50% c'est le
ferroviaire on voit les informer des
délais d'attente pour les routes et
l'autre truc ben nous on est ouvert
assez tard le soir jusqu'à 23 heures le
fait que les heures passées 17 18h sont
très peu fréquentés mais c'est comme
n'importe quoi si on est capable de
maximiser la capacité l'attente
existante on va un peu écraser la courbe
et on va être capable de passer au
travers de
moins moins savoir que tout ce qui était
attendu merci de nous avoir rappelé
cette expression maintenant célèbre
merci Monsieur hembloux d'avoir été avec
nous merci d'invitation pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]